ad 1066 in this year was consecrated the
Minster of Westminster on childermass
day and King Edward died on the eve of
twelfth day and he was buried on twelfth
day within the newly consecrated Church
of Westminster and Harold the Earl
succeeded to the kingdom of England even
as the King had granted it to him and
Men also had chosen him there too and he
was crowded as King on 12th day and that
same year that he became king he went
out with a fleet against William Earl of
Normandy and the wild came toss to the
Earl into humbo with 60 ships edwin the
Earl came with the land horse and drove
him out and the boat men were soaked
inland and he went to Scotland with
twelve vessels and Harold the King of
Norway met him with 300 ships and Tosti
submitted to him and they both went into
Humber and they came to York and walk
out the Earl and Edwin the Earl fought
against them and the king of the
Norwegians had the victory and it was
made known to King Harold how it there
was done and had happened and he came
there with a great army of Englishmen
and met him at Stamford Bridge and slew
him and the old trusty and boldly
overcame all the army and the while
William vo landed the hastings on some
michael's day and harold came from the
north and fought against him before all
his army had come up
and there he felt his two brothers birth
and laugh wing and William subdued the
land and he came to Westminster an
archbishop Aldred consecrated him King
and men paid him tribute to live with
him hostages and afterwards bought their
land and then there was Leia Frick Abbot
of Peterborough in the same expedition
and there he sickened and came home and
was dead soon thereafter on All Hallows
Mass night God be merciful to his soul
in his day was all bliss and all good in
Peterborough and he was dear to all
people so that the King gave to st.
Peter and to him
the abbacy at Burton and that of
Coventry which lay rich the Earl who was
his uncle before had made and that of
crow land and that of thorny and he
conferred so much of good upon the
Minster of Peterborough in gold and in
silver and investments and in land as
never any other did before him nor any
after him after golden bruh became a
wretched borough then chose the monks
favorite brand the Provost by reason
that he was a very good man and very
wise and sent him then to Edgar the
ætheling by reason that the people of
the land supposed that he should become
king and the earthling granted him then
when King William heard say that then he
was very Roth and said that the abbot
had despised him then when good men
between them and reconciled them by
reason that the abbot was a good man
then gave he the king forty marks of
gold for a reconciliation and then
thereafter lived he a little while but
three years after that came every
tribulation in every evil to the
Minister God have mercy on it
[Music]